negli anni 90 c'era un detto che
caratterizzava internet cioè che su
internet
nessuno sa se sei un cane è l'obiettivo
di belletto era far capire appunto come
fosse facile essere anonimi su internet
questa cosa negli anni è cambiata molto
secondo me l'hanno a che più
caratterizza questo cambiamento è stato
il 2008 la domanda che mi pongo oggi con
voi e che mi pongono tempo è nel futuro
nel 2020 o anche più in là saremo sempre
più anonimi o avremo sempre meno
anonimato su internet e quale delle due
opzioni possiamo considerare essere la
migliore ora la prima questione è cosa
succede cosa è successo nel 2008 nel
2008 è successa una cosa molto
interessante cioè che i social network
sono diventati un fenomeno sociale
sempre più grande e i social network in
maniera indiretta non era questo non era
il loro obiettivo ma in maniera
indiretta hanno reso sempre più
difficile essere anonimi su internet se
giocate a poker nel mondo del poker c'è
un detto che fa capire perché questo
fenomeno della mancanza di privacy sia
in parte dovuto ai social network cioè
il detto è che se a un tavolo di poker
entro i primi cinque minuti non capite
che il pollo il pollo siete voi in
questo caso il prodotto di questi social
network siamo tutti noi
nel senso che i social network quasi
tutti e fanno guadagnano attraverso un
industria che l'industria
dell'advertising il nesso logico fra le
due fra le due industrie che sembra
molto poco connesse e il fatto che
l'obiettivo dell'industria
dell'advertising e vendere a tutti noi
dei prodotti e i social network così
come molte altre aziende tecnologiche
hanno un quantitativo di dati su di noi
quasi allucinante l'idea è che se
riusciamo a usare questi dati per capire
che è meglio cosa interessa al singolo
consumatore allora avremo una più alta
probabilità di convincere quel
consumatore a spendere dei soldi quando
questo il mercato dell'advertising sono
circa 500 29 miliardi di dollari l'anno
che è una cifra incredibile stiamo
parlando del pil di un paese come il
belgio è a questo questo fenomeno che è
un fenomeno puramente economico si
aggiunge un altro problema altro
problema è un problema più psicologico
cioè che negli anni sono state fatte
diverse ricerche in cui si è provato che
un utente una persona fra scegliere
privacy e sicurezza e scegliere il
conforto alla comunità quasi sempre
sceglierà il conforto alla comunità
se il la percezione del rischio è una
percezione remota cioè se non
consideriamo il rischio come una cosa
molto probabile allora molto
probabilmente preferiremo il comfort
alla alla sicurezza o alla privacy
la realtà dei fatti però è che se io ora
vi chiedessi di spogliarvi quanti di voi
sarebbero disposti a farlo credo nessuno
il motivo di questa cosa che chiaramente
percepita e anch'io percepire questa
situazione con una situazione pericolosa
nel senso che l'imbarazzo il pudore mi
farebbero stare abbastanza male se
dicesse di spogliarmi il punto che su
internet
noi ci spogliamo quotidianamente e siamo
protetti tra virgolette abbiamo questo
senso di falsa sicurezza che ci è dato
dal fatto che questi social network e
buona parte dei siti su cui che noi
visitiamo sono difficili da capire per
il singolo utente e allo stesso tempo di
nuovo ci danno in questo finto senso
senso della privacy ora borat è un modo
simpatico di spiegare il problema la
realtà è che sempre più spesso negli
anni vediamo soprattutto adolescenti
suicidarsi per quello che i loro
compagni di scuola postano su facebook
piuttosto che su altri social network
c'è un ulteriore problema che
non solo siamo nudi e la gente ci guarda
quando siamo su internet ma tutto quello
che noi facciamo viene registrato
costantemente di nuovo cercando di fare
un paragone con la vita reale è come se
vivesse a londra quanti voi siamo andati
a londra che è pieno di telecamere e
quindi ogni giorno noi ci svegliamo
nella nostra vita online compiamo tutti
i nostri ai nostri gesti che possa
andare su facebook piuttosto che
guardare il nostro conto in banca
eccetera eccetera
siamo completamente nudi e siamo
registrati ora
il il punto è che quando parlo di
registrazione intendo dire circa 600
terabyte di dati al giorno se volessimo
trasformare questo in ore video
parleremmo di 150.000 film da due ore
ciascuno
se uno di noi volesse analizzare o
vedere questi questi dati che vengono
raccolti in un giorno solo da un'azienda
sola credo facebook ci servirebbero 35
anni che è almeno se pensandoci è una
cosa incredibile perché di nuovo ogni
giorno è come se facebook raccogliesse
35 anni di ore video su tutti noi
la domanda chiaramente perché mi
dovrebbe interessare come singolo
cittadino come singolo utente perché mi
interessa perché alla fine questo
sistema funziona in maniera perfetta per
tutti noi nel senso che è il tipico
fenomeno del free riding nel senso che
noi abusiamo di servizi in maniera
gratuita e questi servizi migliorano la
nostra vita
quindi la domanda che ci poniamo è
questo è un problema un po un problema
in futuro la mia risposta è sì a uno dei
problemi che abbiamo con questo con
questa raccolta frenetica di dati e il
fatto che come dicevo prima
nessun nessun umano è in grado di
analizzare queste questi quantitativi di
dati che benché vengono accolti
quotidianamente per cui facciamo
affidamento alle macchine nello
specifico facciamo affidamento degli
algoritmi che si chiama go ritmi di
machine learning
ora mi perdoneranno i cultori della
materia ma machine learning è
fondamentalmente la statistica applicata
a grandi quantitativi di dati attraverso
dei computer
il problema della statistica è che la
statistica per sua natura è un errore
intrinseco e quindi una uno dei problemi
che tu che ci poniamo spesso che chi si
occupa della materia si pone è come fare
a minimizzare questi errori perché
altrimenti quando quando uso algoritmo
di machine learning è probabile che io
faccio delle deduzioni sbagliate su una
determinata persona
ora gli algoritmi mascelloni in
tendenzialmente vengono state per 2x2
per due cose la prima cosa e
classificare dell'entità che dire questa
persona è un uomo una donna questa
persona è ricco povero eccetera eccetera
l'altra cosa imparare delle cose su in
qualcuno in maniera tale di nuovo se lo
guardiamo dal punto di vista
dell'advertising per capire cosa può
interessare a un determinato utente
c'è un problema che unto ciò questo
significa che noi fondamentalmente
stiamo dando in outsourcing delle
decisioni sempre più importanti sulla
vita di tutti i giorni a delle macchine
ora in generale una cosa che gli
algoritmi di mascellani non riescono a
fare oggi e probabilmente non
riusciranno mai a fare e che non hanno
empatia
quindi se noi abbiamo questo stream di
dati che va dal giorno in cui siamo nati
ad oggi e come tutti quanti abbiamo
commesso degli errori in passato ci sono
delle cose che preferiremmo non
menzionare l'algoritmo di machine
learning non considera niente di tutto
ciò valga a dei dati fa l'analisi fidati
ci dà delle risposte
in più la probabilità che uno a caso di
noi capisca effettivamente cosa fa
l'algoritmo è praticamente pari allo
zero anzi è quasi preoccupante perché se
parlate con una persona qualunque che si
occupa di reti neurali vi dirà che
determinate decisioni che migliorano i
risultati delle reti neurali non hanno
una spiegazione del senso che vengono
vengono cambiati dei parametri e perché
quel parametri dovrebbero funzionare
meglio di altri
è una domanda a cui nessuno una risposta
ci ritroveremo in un futuro
purtroppo molto più vicino di quanto
pensiamo a avere a che fare con delle
istituzioni
usano questi algoritmi per prendere
delle decisioni importanti sulla vita di
tutti i giorni e per il problema di cui
sopra non saremo in grado di confutare
queste decisioni
ora questo non succede non credo succeda
molto in italia ma succede tantissimo
negli stati uniti nel senso che il
machine learning applicato a quello che
di solito viene definito big data
abbiamo utilizzato già oggi per capire
quanto deve essere alto il premio
assicurativo sulla vostra assicurazione
sulla salute viene utilizzato per capire
quanto deve essere alto il tasso di
interesse sul vostro mutuo s e darvi un
mutuo abbiamo utilizzato dai governi per
corredare le attività di persone per
capire se quelle persone sono state
coinvolte in qualche qualche attentato
piuttosto che qualunque altro atto
criminale
un autore molto famoso di fantascienza
william gibson ha scritto di recente su
twitter che una delle domande che lui si
pone spesso quando della nuova
tecnologia e cosa farebbe la corea del
nord se avesse accesso a questa
tecnologia
il punto è che noi implicitamente stiamo
creando una tecnologia che non capiamo e
che potenzialmente darebbe a un paese
come la corea del nord la possibilità di
creare l'equivalente di uno stato
totalitario su internet
ciò detto spesso purtroppo nel mio
lavoro sono foriero di cattive notizie e
l'obiettivo di questo torchia cercare di
avere una visione costruttiva perché di
nuovo internet e lo sharing in generale
migliore ha migliorato in passato e
migliora le nostre virtù torah e senza
interni in termini molto pratici senza
internet io non avrei un lavoro per cui
è importante che questo che che internet
sopravvive che lo sharing sopravviva è
inoltre importante la possibilità di
mantenere il concetto di free riding
perché altrimenti quello che viene
definito il terzo mondo non avrebbe
accesso non avrebbe la possibilità di
pagare per le risorse su internet che
noi tutti utilizziamo utilizziamo oggi
ci sono quattro cose che secondo me
possiamo fare come come cittadini per
migliorare la situazione
alcune di queste richiedono un lavoro di
concerto con le istituzioni e le aziende
e altre invece sono delle cose che
possiamo fare noi singolarmente
la prima cosa è imporre alle aziende di
avere una sorta di data di scadenza sui
dati che vengono raccolti cioè l'idea è
ok tu puoi raccogliere tutti i dati che
vuoi ma dopo 30 giorni sei mesi un anno
quei dati devono necessariamente essere
cancellati questo permette a noi di
avere il famoso diritto di essere
dimenticati e rende più difficile per le
aziende applicare degli algoritmi su dei
dati storici che magari noi non volevamo
condividere se avessimo saputo che quel
tipo di algoritmo sarebbe stato
utilizzato su quei dati la seconda la
seconda proposta è quella di avere delle
etichette molto simili alle etichette
che abbiamo sul cibo che è il valore
nutrizionale del cibo quest'etichetta
devono essere applicate ai siti web e
alle applicazioni sia sui cellulari sia
computer perché perché in realtà il
metodo legale attraverso il quale le
aziende si è proprio nei nostri dati e
fanno quello che vogliono
con i nostri dati sono questi contratti
spesso chiamati euro e questi contratti
non sono fatti per essere letti di
esseri umani sono fatti da avvocati e
l'obiettivo è rendere quasi impossibile
la lettura da parte di un essere umano
in più questi contratti sono fatti in
maniera tale che fondamentalmente al
momento in cui noi accendiamo un sito o
scaricare un'applicazione stiamo dando
completo controllo dei nostri dati a a
una determinata azienda questa cosa sta
cambiando lentamente su esempio i
sistemi operativi come ios quindi quello
che avete subito i vostri iphone
cioè quando una determinata applicazione
vuole accedere alla telecamera piuttosto
che i contatti viene fuori un pop up che
vi chiede vuoi dare l'autorizzazione a
questa applicazione precedenti ma non è
abbastanza
bisognerebbe anche rendere comprensibile
all'essere umano cosa si fa con quei
lati
la terza opzione avere la possibilità di
pagare per dei servizi cioè ad esempio
se voi siete dei fruitori appassionati
di facebook
dovreste poter avere a due opzioni
l'opzione gratuita in cui facebook ha il
diritto di collezionare i dati e le
opzioni a pagamento in cui voi pagate o
un abbonamento mensile oppure a consumo
è però facebook a quel punto non deve
essere in grado di collezionare i dati
su di voi
ora questo è una cosa che sta già
accadendo nel senso che ci sono dei
servizi sia di google sia di altre
aziende che si stanno muovendo più in
questa direzione però ancora non è
abbastanza
la quarta opzione è l'unica cosa che in
realtà potete fare già da oggi quando
andate a casa cioè utilizzare dei tool
che sono a breve si friendly cioè dei
tool che rendono più difficile il
tracciamento delle persone su internet
sono tool che bloccano i siti che fanno
vedere la pubblicità sono dei tool come
tor torre più o meno un labirinto online
in modo tale che quando io vado sul sito
è impossibile per il proprietario del
sito capire da dove viene la connessione
quindi è impossibile per il proprietario
del sito capire che sono io a oppure
potenzialmente qualcosa come bitcoin che
rende più difficile collegare collegare
una transazione finanziaria con una
persona fisica problema dei tool di
privacy è che spesso vengono utilizzati
come uno spauracchio dai governi non
solo dai governi totalitari ma anche dai
dei nostri governi anche dai governi
come l'inghilterra perché siccome
garantiscono più confidenzialità e più
privacy vengono anche utilizzati da
terroristi e criminali per le loro
attività il problema è che ad oggi
questi sono gli unici tour che noi
abbiamo a disposizione per proteggere
noi stessi per cui è importante che
restino legali per quanto
per quanto più tempo possibile finché
questo questo tipo di problema non verrà
risolto ora il problema
la domanda è cosa cosa succederà in
futuro beh io spero che nel 2020 avremo
la possibilità sia di essere dei cani su
internet sia paradossalmente di avere
più identità su internet cioè quasi un
epping 1 a 1 fra la nostra identità
virtuale nella nostra identità reale per
poter fare cose con me a votare votare
on line oppure aprire un conto in banca
senza dover firmare nessun tipo di
contratto
il punto è che è fondamentale avere la
possibilità di avere entrambe le cose
altrimenti ci ritroveremo in uno stato
totalitario sul web grazie mille